je me suis dit quels sont les dix choses
les 10 bonnes choses du confinement
parce qu'on est tous confinés et je vous
ai fait le top 10 vous ferai tous les
jours un petit top 10 et le top 10 des
bonnes choses à faire en confinement à
l'eau aujourd'hui les top 10 des bonnes
choses du confinement voilà des trucs à
apprendre
voilà alors numéro 10 déjà tu peux te
présenter à la prochaine saison de top
chef c'est sur un certain parce que en
fait tout le monde a découvert qu'ils
avaient des trucs de leur frigo
tout le monde a découvert qu'ils
savaient faire au moins un oeuf au plat
tout le monde a dit que la cuisine mais
non c'était pas si dur voir quand j'ai
fait ma tourte aux champignons mais
j'étais fier de moi on dirait que
j'avais gagné roland garros klein non
mais sans rigoler j'ai fait un tour de
champignons à la vigne de l'anguille est
mon frère mais j'étais comme un ouf
donc on est d'accord réussi à faire
fonctionner tant pour ce qui était
exceptionnel j'ai vu ça va exactement ma
vie j'ai réussi à faire fonctionner mon
four il est chaud il était très chaud
mon four au oui alors au en neuvième
position des top 10 à ton appartement va
être le temple de la propre aux tic
c'est vrai alors c'est où l'un de
l'autre parce que franchement là on n'a
plus d'excusés
ce confinement c'est le moment pour
faire du tri pour faire du minage pour
nettoyer des trucs auxquels qui pensent
jamais donc forcément ça ça du bon dans
le confinement en confirmant tout le
monde il faut se laver les mains faut
désinfecter préfère si on perd ça faut
nettoyer les placards après tout sans
bon donc après ce confinement
normalement chez toi sans déconner tout
va briller comme ça c'est un type de ouf
on est d'accord devait être le ménage
vous seriez d'accord
en une également des trucs bon du
confinement si tu va enfin devenir
l'artiste qui sommeille en toi est vrai
si tu as toujours rêvé d'apprendre un
instrument ou apprendre à faire du
dessin à faire de la peinture c'est le
moment
il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit voilà
qui vont syrah du confinement pour faire
des toiles pour chanter pour écrire des
morceaux pour faire de la musique en
famille voilà vous je suis sûr vous avez
un artiste qui sommeille en vous vous
c'est quoi votre vie notre spécialité
artistique vous parlions de gilles c koi
tu sais faire
un mois c'est l'écrire j'écris j'écris
j'écris j'écris j'écris mais personne ne
le publier les frères thomas frey
retrait d'higuain à l'ostal il est créé
des cartes postales ennabaoui naulleau
naulleau c'est quoi vous bon c'est
écrire
oui très clair oui là on a du temps à
l'écriture ça demande du temps et là on
a des journées entières c'est parfait
très bien
castaldi moi je chante très bien vous le
savez je sais plus et puis vous faites à
l'instrument oui c'était du pipeau non
non et non mais sans rire et il peut
jouer la marseillaise avec son cul non
mais sans le nom de quoi en sixième
position
si tu va enfin pouvoir dire sans mentir
que tu as lu tel bouquin ou vu tel film
voilà où en tout cas peut-être lu tel
livre parce que c'est vrai que voilà
mine de rien là c'est le moment de se
ressourcer de lire
voilà moi moi chaque jour ça chez nous
je dévore un à deux bouquins par jour
voilà quoi hier le catalogue kavala et
briques à rabat je n'ai vu donner aux
gens de donner aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la chaussure encore je relis
une fois de plus la somme war is all
away ce livre j'adore ça parle de loi la
semoy c'est un mec qui haïssent réveil
il a comme une baraque comme ça il est
assuré pendant la nuit il se réveille
avec une barre qui signe le gala il est
pas là y ait en fait c'est la sowaer moi
ça c'est quoi la semoy ça parle de quoi
je parle de quoi l'assommoir merci la
somme à saint tropez
la céleste au moins et oui un troc insee
l'alcool n'avait là où on se fait
matraquer par l'alcool non alors c'est
pas ce livre là que j'ai lu c'est le
grand moun alain fourny oui j'adore mots
un grand moule j'adore des histoires là
d'or le vainqueur du grand meaulnes
grand moule j'adore cette histoire sia
santé de ma gueule bande de cons là mais
non non non non non pas parce que
l'histoire du grand meaulnes est
exceptionnel voilà je le conseille à
tous ceux qui nous regardent
franchement j'adore cette ce livre je
les dévorer
les bouffées d'air aux cinquième et en
sixième position
pour ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir un
jardin c'est génial ça fait des mois
qu'il pleut tout le temps est là depuis
qu'on est confiné il fait beau tous les
jours donc ton jardin va être hyper
frais il perd valasse je vous dis non
mais c'est vrai parce que tous les gens
qui ont un jardin thouars a l'impression
qu'ils reviennent de vacances au mois
d'août le jardin voilà il faut
l'entretenir il faut couper tout le
monde va être jardinier en fait à la
part je confirme on voit des jardiniers
cuisiniers écrivains devraient donc on
va et pelletier fonctions aux frères on
va être l'hommage unique avec le match
en cinquième position
tu auras un corps de rêve sur la plage
puisque maintenant l'excusé de pousser
voilà ta tête tu as du temps pour faire
du sport
forcément tous les jours le sport ça
peut même se faire à la maison tu peux
avoir des très bons trucs à la maison et
là on va tout savoir des abdos des pecs
des bras de ouf
franchement voilà ça c'est le bon truc
du confinement aussi on est d'accord les
gars we know l'oim sur voila merci au
numéro 24 des animaux de compagnie sont
au top
m les animaux sont actifs parce que
jamais ton chat le ton chien ne t'ont
pas autant vu ça veut dire que là même
où ils doivent se dire la touche alt au
chien et comme ceux d'hier est sûre il
serait direct son travail parce qu'on
n'est pas encore là ton chien ou son
chat
ils appellent leurs hotspots chiens ou
chats et dewey banon va toi quoi toi
aussi s'est fait tirer mais c'est un
truc de en fout.ce le 12 mai à des
licenciements de partout là bas moi il
est toute la journée à la maison
bah ouais je sais pas moi mais moi j'ai
un mois j'ai moi j'ai mon chien et ouais
il fait j'aurais fait une émission de la
maison je crois qu'il vient ouf
il n'a pas compris que voilà c'est
terminé pour lui ah mais soulignant mais
des chiens et les chats ils sont enquis
en numéro 3 la planète faire un break
c'est vrai parce qu'en vrai mine de rien
pour l'écologie je vous dis en ce moment
par exemple à paris l'eire n'a jamais
été aussi pures de puces break
quarante ans c'est un truc de fou bah
parce qu en fait personne ne sort là et
mine de rien c'est la nature qui respire
et qui voit plus nos gueules qui voit
plus nos voitures qui voit plus le pot
d'échappement qui voit plus nos avions
qui voit plus tout ça donc la nature est
en train de respirer
et dire qu'ils nous font chier en numéro
2 tu peux devenir écolo
l'écologie c'est très important c'est
aussi le moment pour se remettre en
question l'institut et ennui tu peux
nous tester de nouvelles choses
écolo pour ton ménages recycler des
objets donner une nouvelle vie à tes
vêtements en plus c'est vrai ya rien à
acheter en ce moment et au même si tu
veux faire les magasins tu peux pas mais
non rien donc
et ben en vrai battu peu voilà faire des
petits qui des petits délires et en
numéro 1
les chéris dormir le bon truc ya dans le
confinement
c'est dormir voilà par gilles verdez qui
a une tête on dirait qu'il n'a pas dormi
depuis deux cent cinquante deux ans
non mais franchement normalement une
tête comme ça pendant le confinement
s'est pas posé frère qui n'a pas des
valises le gars à mon frère il a le truc
des valises il a le chariot entier savez
le truc là on évalue zèle pas ce faire
il a 18 valises mon frère c'est le gars
c'est charles de gaulle c'est l'aéroport
charles de gaulle
ça c'est un truc de ouf normalement tu
dois dormir t'as rien à faire
mon frère d'or un peu sans déconner
c'est un truc de ouf hélas combien mes
frères et s'est passé quelque chose ou
frère fait des simulations de deux trucs
qui font dormir on faire je vais me
maquiller demain non t'emmerde pas avec
ça tu as un carré il t'emmerde pas avec
cela a été très bien comme ça tiens
d'ailleurs quel est le truc qui vous
fait le plus qui fait vous pendant ce
confinement dans tout ce que j'ai dit
c'est dormir frachon à dormir parce que
là on dort comme des oufs 1 et comme en
plus on se réveille il ya détaillé qui
tombent en temps des trucs de ouf à la
télé ou quoi ta qu'une envie c'est
d'aller dormir tant rats sera mon frère
tu dis la vérité
allumez la télé frère le mec qui reste
sur bfm tv où ces news ou lci tous les
jours faire aller même si la pâle
coronavirus fertility reste chez lui il
a qu'une envie c'est une combien de
chercher qu'on la met loin de tout ça
c'est un truc de dégâts il annonce que
des mauvaises nouvelles
l'article a nnoncé reconnaît non mais le
eric sans déconner c'est un truc de
gestion apaisée
j'ai une question à poser leader russe
ira la quitte à fâcher
quitte à soulever des lèvres mine de
rien ils n'en font pas un peu trop
toutes ces chaînes infos sont déconner
je dis la vérité
les mecs bien sûr que la situation est
très grave bien sûr mais on a
l'impression qu'ils vont chercher aussi
à faire le truc voilà qui va être
escalade de lara sera sans décoller en
avril à paris et qui c'est qui cartonne
je te jure je dis pas ça parce que c'est
mon pote c'est jean marc morandini y
arrive
record d'audience près de 500000 le
matin pourquoi parce que ils te mettent
pas lara sera il te raconte des trucs
il ya des témoignages et les trucs il
dit des trucs graff mais c'est passera
même la forme et les moires astra et e
sans déconner tu as une angoisse mon
frère tu n'as qu'une envie c'est
d'éteindre la télé d'hier va dire mais
moi des épisodes de la petite maison
dans la prairie avec gerald mikscha
fouet et rick perry le mois junte
moi je regarde plus tard et a regardé la
peinture et les noms doivent c'est une
angoisse quotidienne j'ai compris le
truc j'ai compris le bas il n'y a pas de
problème là c'est pas la peine de mener
les choses quoi ils font ça ils
prévoient efforts à jour pourquoi il
faut que ça marche maintenant les gars
alors décharge il faut dire que tout le
reste est arrêté il ya plus que ça ouais
mais pas tout le reste est à l'arrêt il
ya plus de sport la politique on en
parle que par rapport aux coronavirus
donc c'est un peu normal aussi mais il
faut se faire une santé mentale se
décrocher comme on décroche de la broque
il faut se décrocher dès les chaînes
d'info continue caisse en bois ça me
laisse un peu la bn des chaînes d'info
en continu en même temps ça a toujours
fonctionné comme ça pendant les
attentats
c'est extrêmement non c'est particulier
c'est particulier c'est sûr mais je tire
et moi je suis pas d'accord avec vous ni
avec eric parce qu'honnêtement regarder
bfm et réhaussée news et aux aussie est
en fait les gens sont obsédés par ça et
j'ai toujours pensé que les chaînes
d'info ne crée pas l'aktu elle parlait
de ce qui obsède les gens s qui obsède
les gens c'est le corps en un virus donc
les chiens sur haut et fort évoluent ce
feuilleton dramatique pas failli à
nouveaux frais mais oui mais oui mais
mine de rien on a l'impression qu'ils
vont te chercher la mauvaise nouvelle
ça veut dire nous on essaie de chercher
des bonnes nouvelles eux ils vont
essayer de trouver à des mecs j'ai un
truc j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle ici
abbas en nombre de titres non mais ces
messages écrits pas d'accord et trois
minutes
eric pourquoi ils font ça alors mais
parce que simplement quand il ya une
crise il ya des pics d'audimat donc
écoute cyniquement c'est une très bonne
période pour une très mauvaise période
pour le reste de l'économie mais pour
les chaînes d'info c'est noël tous les
jours c'est oui ben là bas non non mais
c'est vrai que il cherche toujours à
clips bête et c'est avec moi moi
j'aurais pu les voilà j'ai pu en voir
les nouvelles seront là pour rien de
nouveau en fête au final c'est ça le
problème se cale pas d'infos et voilà
ils ont piles et répète sans cesse la
même chose
ian nouveau il ya même médecin tous les
matins qui braquent compte que voilà et
le virus s'amplifie et vous et basta et
rien ou
donc honnêtement il n'y a pas grand
chose d'autre à a parlé sur les très
honnête si cher on est un prénom qui
cherchent une mauvaise nouvelle
bon après voilà laurent ça y est vous
qui travaillez sur des chagossiens peut
effectivement moi j'ai jamais aussi peu
regarder les chaînes d'info en plus
quand il ya des enfants dans
l'appartement si vous leur mettez les
pauvres c'est hyper hyper ambitieux gêne
donc faut décrocher parce que si on veut
garder le moral et c'est quand même la
balle de touba il faut regarder autre
chose et pour c'est autre chose sinon
c'est infernal
un ferme